l' affaire grégory maintenant cette
affaire tragique at elle le pouvoir de
faire perdre leur sérénité à tous ceux
qui s'en approchent policiers gendarmes
magistrats ou avocats et le juge simon
qui est en charge actuellement du
dossier magistrat discret dont chacun
avant efficacité yens accorder une
nouvelle fois une interview plutôt
explosive s'était fait piéger au cours
de cette interview plus long que prévu
ou elle suit il utilise la presse pour
provoquer un dénouement pour l'instant
point d'interrogation et dans ses propos
magazine le nouveau détective
le juge dit par exemple que bernard
laroche a peut-être enlevé grégory en
tout cas les observateurs pensent que
cette instruction qui dure maintenant
depuis cinq années pourrait connaître un
proche dénouement and gas berger les
confidences du juge simon qui s'attarde
aujourd'hui sur le point capital de son
enquête qui a tué grégory un juge qui
semble convaincu de l'heure du crime
c'est après 17h30 que l'enfant aurait
été noyés dit il une heure qui
innocenteraient christine villemin la
mère de grégory car à 17h30 christine
participer aux recherches
deuxième révélation grégory a été
assassiné par plusieurs personnes j'ai
trois hypothèses parmi lesquels je ne
peux encore tranché dit il mais tout 3
évoque bernard laroche
il a peut-être enlevé grégory dit le
juge de là à être son assassin il y à un
pas que je ne peux pas encore franchir
je n'ai aucune preuve
hypothèse qui confirmerait les
déclarations de m garot la semaine
dernière l'avocat de christine affirmait
alors que l'on s'acheminait vers un non
lieu de sa cliente
troisième point le juge simon affirme
avoir reçu des menaces contre lui et
contre ses petits enfants
or ajoute-t-il seuls les grands parents
de grégory connaissent l'existence de ma
famille monique et albert villemin déjà
entendu à plusieurs reprises par le juge
autant d'éléments qui permettent de
penser que le juge simon entend boucler
son affaire sous peu si monsieur le juge
a dit ça c'est que il est vraisemblable
qu'il a data aux quelque chose c'est
certainement pas un monsieur qui tentera
poire et le fromage dit tiens pradier le
détective est sympathique et si on bat
c'est un peu parce que ce même s'ils me
l'avait dit genre jamais été très honoré
néo kaka j'aurais réagi à mon journal
entretien explosif pourtant selon
certaines rumeurs le juge simon
contesterait maintenant avoir accordé
une interview
destiné à être publié